ما أذهلك عندما رأيت هذا ،
فأنت تعلم أن جون كلاهما دهشة
على غرار ما وصفته للتو ،
هل حدث هذا في تاريخ
جمهوريتنا أن رئيسًا سابقًا هو
أن قاضيًا فيدراليًا
اتخذ قرارًا على ما يبدو أنه هناك  قد يكون
دليلًا على جريمة في مقر إقامة
رئيس سابق ، إنه مجرد
أمر مذهل ، ولكن من ناحية أخرى كما هو الحال مع
العديد من الأشياء مع الإدارة السابقة ،
فإنه
ليس من المستغرب أيضًا أن
يجد الرئيس السابق نفسه حاليًا في
مرمى نيران الكثيرين.  تحقيقات جنائية متنوعة ومختلفة ،
وبصراحة ، فإن أول ما فكرت
به عندما سمعت إشعارًا
بأمر التفتيش هو أي تحقيق قد
يكون جزءًا من هناك العديد من
الخيارات هنا ، إنه يدور حرفيًا
ولكني أعتقد أن الأمر الذي قمنا به  تم التركيز
على أن الأشخاص من المشهد الذين
يُزعم أن الإبلاغ عنهم هو أكثر
منطقية ومتابعة تعليقات القاعدة
من قبل هذا الأمر.  هذا النوع من
الأشياء التي قد تحدث في
حال كنا نعرف الأشخاص
في الأرشيف الوطني ومكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
فكر جيدًا ربما
انتهى الأمر ببعض المستندات السرية عن طريق الصدفة في
الصناديق الشخصية للرئيس التي ذهبت إلى
mar-a-lago
لم يكن مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي (fbi) قد اتخذ خطوة
جذرية وخطيرة كهذه ما لم يكن
لديهم معلومات جيدة تشير إلى أن
هذا كان نتيجة معرفة بعض
الأفعال المتعمدة المتعمدة لإزالة
المستندات السرية أو المستندات الحساسة
في انتهاك لبعض القوانين الفيدرالية ،
لذا أعتقد ما  سنرى
ادعاء خطير للغاية عندما يتم الكشف عنه في
النهاية
كما قال إيلي يمكنني أن أرى أنه
سيقول بالفعل أنك تعرف بالضبط أن
هذه كانت تذكارات أو
كانت تعرف رسائل حب من uh Kim
jong-un et  cetera et cetera ، لكنني أريد
أن أقول الآن إن الرئيس ،
الرئيس السابق للولايات المتحدة ،
لم يتعامل مع المستندات السرية
بشكل صحيح ، لقد شاهدته يفعل ذلك كنت جالسًا
فيه  شاهدته طائرة معه وهو
يتصفح المستندات ويلقي بعضها بعيدًا ويمزق
بعضها ويضع بعضها في جيبه
لأنني أتذكر على وجه التحديد
أنني أتساءل لماذا يذهب هؤلاء في جيبه ،
لذا أعتقد أن هذا سيكون
ممتعًا حقًا والآن بعد caitlyn مثل
مثلما قال علي الآن بعد أن أعطتنا كايتلين
هذا السياق ، أعتقد أن هناك
شيئًا كبيرًا هناك ، لا أعتقد
أنه سيكون مجرد أحرف أعتقد أنه
قد يكون حول العمليات العسكرية ،
هذا أنا أتوقع أنني أريد أن أكون واضحًا ولكن
يمكنني  انظر
إلى الرئيس السابق وهو يفكر في أن هذه كانت
رائعة أو ممتعة ولم نكن بيتًا أبيض
يتبع القواعد
وسأخبرك أن التعامل مع
المعلومات السرية لم يكن شيئًا تم
الضغط عليه فعليًا بشكل يومي
أو أسبوعي أو شهري